Good morning church.
What a great day it is to be able
to worship together like this.
Uh, we're so thankful for it.
Here's how I wanna start today,
a little differently than normal.
I want you to put yourself in this parable
that I came across this week
and I want you to just kind of stop everything,
close your eyes and just try to imagine yourself
as the one speaking in this parable.
So close your eyes, kind of focus in
and just imagine you are the one saying what I'm saying.
The notification pops up on my cracked phone screen at
2:47 PM on a Tuesday.
Your student loans have been paid off.
I'm sitting in my studio apartment in the
worst part of town.
The place I ended up after dad's business collapsed
and took our family's reputation with it.
Three years of scandal, bankruptcy lawsuits.
Three years of watching friends cross the
street to avoid me.
Three years of living off ramen
and the shame of a name that used to mean something.
My legs haven't worked right since the car accident.
During the worst of it when I was driving dad's Mercedes,
that was repoed back to the dealership
and I couldn't see through my tears,
the surgeries we couldn't afford, the physical therapy
that insurance wouldn't cover.
Just another thing. Broken in a life full of broken things.
I refreshed the app certain it's a
mistake, but, but there it is.
$127,000 in debt. Gone.
Not just forgiven, absorbed, paid in full
by someone I've never met.
The letter arrives the next day on letterhead I recognized
but never expected to see, addressed to me Johnson
and Associates, the tech company my dad tried to sue
during his downward spiral, the CEO,
whose reputation he tried to destroy in the press.
Dear Marcus, your father and I were roommates in college.
Best friends. Actually, I never forgot his kindness
to me when I had nothing.
I know he lost his way. And I know you've paid the price.
I'd like to offer you a position on our team, full benefits,
stock options, and a salary
that will let you live with dignity.
Not because you've earned it, but
because that's what friends do for each other,
even across years and mistakes and broken trust.
Your father's love for me, when we were young was real.
This is my way of honoring that.
The job starts Monday if you want it.
I stare at the letter until the words blur.
This isn't charity, this isn't pity.
This is something else entirely love
that reaches across the wreckage of failure
and says, you belong at my table.
Love that remembers friendship.
When friendship seemed impossible.
It's the second chance I never saw coming. It's grace.
Okay, church, how would you feel in that moment?
Overwhelmed, humbled,
stunned, right?
Your life had been over. You thought you'd been forgotten.
You thought nothing but pain was gonna be
present in your life.
And now all of a sudden life,
it's a powerful parable, isn't it?
But I want us to also think a layer deeper
like Jesus often did with his parables.
Let's take it below the surface.
Isn't that your story?
If you're in Christ I, isn't
that the story of every believer spiritually
cast away, crippled by sin, nothing
to offer yet God gives us his covenant love,
his faithful mercy, his loving kindness.
It's the Hebrew word I'm gonna say a number of times today.
He said It's all over the Old Testament,
but this is the point it makes in Deuteronomy
seven verse nine.
It says, know therefore that the Lord your God is God.
The faithful God who keeps covenant and steadfast love.
That's that word hesed with those who love him
and keep his commandments to a thousand generations.
This is our God, the faithful one
who loves with kindness is loyal.
That's what we're gonna study today.
First, how each of us desperately need that kindness,
But then also how that flips around.
And God shows his kindness through us to others
who need it as well.
And so go ahead and take your copy of God's Word
and turn with me to Second Samuel chapter eight
as we continue our journey through this book.
We're Gonna be in Second Samuel chapters eight
through 10 today.
And here's where we're headed. We're gonna again see the
kindness of God, but specifically we're gonna see in that
how grace pursues the undeserving and
and how some people don't always respond well to that.
But I want you to remember also where we're at in the story.
This narrative has taken us through David's ascension
to the kingship.
And so you'll see the chart again on the screen.
This is the high point of David's rule in Israel.
This is where we are now, where God is blessing David
with land, with victories, even promised this eternal legacy
that was gonna come through the Son of David,
which we now know to be Jesus eternally.
But this is where we're at.
We're at the highest peak of it, yet as good
as it was at this point.
Next week, chapter 11 begins the downfall,
David and of Israel.
So we're not there yet.
Let's enjoy while we last here in this section
of the passage.
But, but just know that that's coming starting next week.
So here in chapter eight we see that God has given David all
of these things and we see David's military conquests
and how God is expanding the kingdom,
making them a dominant regional power.
But I wanna just look at two verses here, verse six
and verse 14 here in chapter eight.
And this will show us something I want you to see verse six,
the very end of verse six.
It says, and the Lord gave victory
to David wherever he went.
Now down in verse 14, again, the very end of that verse.
And the Lord gave victory to David wherever he went.
I think it's pretty clear what
I'm trying to say with that, right?
It wasn't military genius, it wasn't superior strategy.
Even though David was the ultimate warrior, right?
He, he was seeing God's hesed kindness in
action in his life.
God was bringing victory. God was bringing victory.
David's kingdom was not being established
because of his worthiness, but because of God's promise.
Remember David was the, the eighth son.
He was out in the field taking care of sheep and,
and God called him to this role.
But listen, that's what God's kindness does.
It establishes unshakeable kingdoms.
That's what we're needing to see from this point here, is
that God's kindness establishes unshakeable kingdoms.
That's why I emphasize those two verses.
Because it was the Lord who was the one building the nation.
It was the Lord who was bringing the victories.
They were relying on God to overcome these enemies
that they previously thought were insurmountable,
impossible enemies to defeat.
And God was bringing, bringing victory.
They looked back to Abraham's promise
hundreds of years earlier.
God said to Abraham, you're gonna have this land.
You're gonna have these, these
families that will be blessed through you.
And they're looking back and God's bringing it.
God's doing it through his people.
God was the one building the kingdom.
But I want you
to think about something even more important than
what they were experiencing back then.
Think about the kingdom of heaven.
It's similar to how David's kingdom was established, not
by his merit, but by God's promise.
The kingdom of heaven is established not
by our righteousness,
but by Christ's righteousness for us, that's
what Romans five 17 says.
Listen to this for if
because of one man's trespass
that's talking about Adam all the way back in the garden
for if because of one man's trespass, death reigned through
that one man, much more will those who receive the abundance
of grace and the free gift of righteousness
reign in life through the one man Jesus Christ.
It's his righteousness. It's his reign that we stand in.
That's how we can reign with him, is
because he reigns to begin with and we receive His grace.
We're a part of it as well.
You're a part of that kingdom of God.
Not because you earned it, but
because you trust in his work for you.
That's the unshakable part. Your work is pretty shaky.
Your foundation, if you're building on yours, is a,
a shifting sand of a foundation.
The unshakeable foundation is the perfection
of Jesus Christ in your place.
God is the one who builds unshakeable kingdoms.
And here's why I remind you of that.
'cause I know my tendency, imagine it's your tendency
as well to default back
to basing my salvation on my works.
Now, you wouldn't say that out loud, right?
'cause that's not the Sunday school answer.
You shouldn't say that out loud like
I'm trying to base myself.
No, you wouldn't. You would say nothing about that.
You would say the right answer, but,
but what happens is that you feel like under the surface
you're trying to earn your way in
and you're gonna be good enough.
You're better than the jerk down the street.
And so you know God's gotta let you in.
It's your works. Or maybe that's not for you.
Maybe the flip side is true for you.
Where you base your assurance on your performance.
How'd you do this week? You know,
like you, you, you really killed it.
You're doing great. You're, you're feeling good that God,
you're assured in your salvation
'cause you did great this week morally.
But those weeks that you train wreck,
you're a little terrified
that somehow God's gonna exclude
you from the kingdom, right?
See, that's basing it all on your works.
It's all wrong. It's the Lord
who gave victory to David.
It's the Lord whose victory over sin is
what guarantees the foundation for your eternity.
Not you, not how well or badly you do.
It's not about you at all. It's about his work for you.
That's the unshakeable part of this.
And listen, that should lead us to rejoice.
That our citizenship in heaven is not
based on our performance.
How well we did or how well we didn't do.
Like it's, it's not based.
It's based on Jesus Christ
for you simply.
And that should lead us to joy in an unshakeable kingdom.
It's his kindness. Well, here's
what happens in chapter nine, we see a new way.
God's kindness shows up.
I'm gonna read the entire chapter here, chapter nine,
and then we're gonna dig deeper into this one.
One of my favorite passages in all of scripture right here,
watch what chapter nine says.
David said, is there still anyone left to the house of Saul
that I may show him kindness for Jonathan's sake?
Now, there was a servant of the house
of Saul whose name was Zeba, and they called him to David.
And the king said to him, are you a zeba?
And he said, I am your servant.
And the king said, is there not still someone of the house
of Saul that I may show the kindness of God to him?
And Zeba said to the king, there's still a son of Jonathan.
He's crippled in his feet.
The king said to him, where is he?
Zeba said to the king, he's in the house of Macke, the son
of Emil at lo debar.
Then King and David sent
and brought him from the house of Macke, the son
of Emil at Lo debar.
And Mephibosheth, the son of Jonathan, son of Saul, came
to David and fell on his face and paid homage.
And David said, Mephibosheth.
And he answered, behold, I am your servant.
And David said to him, do not fear
for I will show you kindness.
That's that. He said, word.
I will show you kindness for the sake
of your father, Jonathan.
And I will restore to you all the land of Saul, your father,
and you shall eat at my table always.
And he paid homage. And he said, what is your servant
that you should show regard for a dead dog such as I?
And then the king called Zeba, Saul's servant said to him,
all that belong to Saul
and to all his house, I've given to your master's grandson,
and you and your sons,
and your servants shall till the land for him
and shall bring in the produce
that your master's grandson may have bred to eat.
But Mephibosheth, your master's grandson shall always
eat at my table.
Now, Zeba had 15 sons, 20 servants.
And Zeba said to the king, according to all of my Lord,
the king commands his servants.
So will your servant do.
So Mephibosheth ate at David's table like
one of the king's sons.
And Mephibosheth had a young son whose name was Micah,
and all who lived in Zebra's house became
Mephibosheth's servants.
So Mephibosheth lived in Jerusalem
and he ate always at the king's table.
Now he was lame in both his feet.
Now I want to, I wants
to notice a couple things about this passage first
before we dig too far into it.
First, look at the initiative by David.
David didn't go out
and say, Hey, is anyone from Saul's house causing trouble?
No. What did he say? He said,
is there anyone from Saul's house that I can bless?
Because remember at that time a new king comes in,
he would've had all the previous regimes family executed so
that none of 'em had a claim to the throne.
And so he's walking around with that opportunity.
But no, what does he do? He says, no.
Is there anyone I can bless? He shows kindness.
Why did he do it? Because of Jonathan's kindness to David
and because Jonathan and David had made a covenant
years before that, I'm gonna bless your family, Jonathan.
Jonathan's like, Hey, when you're the king, bless my family.
David's now the king. He looks for Jonathan's family
and I'm going to bless them with that.
He said kindness. That covenant loyalty kind of kindness.
That's part of the reason. But the other reason is
because David is truly showing the nature of
what a king ought to be in Israel.
Just listen to what Psalm 72 says it.
Verse four, may he defend the cause of the poor
of the people, give deliverance to the children
of the needy, crush, the oppressor.
He delivers the needy when he calls the poor.
And him who has no helper.
He has pity on the weak and the needy.
He saves the lives of the needy.
That's the way the king was supposed to be.
And so David just saying, I wanna do that,
but let's focus also a moment on Mephibosheth's condition.
This is Jonathan's son.
Did you see how it described his life?
It says he was physically broken,
crippled in his feet, lame in his feet.
That actually happened. We kinda skimmed over it
back in chapter four.
On the day Jonathan was killed in the battle.
Mephibosheth was being, well, he was five years old,
being cared for by someone back home.
They heard the news fled from the city
and she drops this 5-year-old.
Mephibosheth breaks his legs.
That's why he is the way he is now.
Years, years later, still crippled by that.
And so he was physically broken.
He was also socially isolated.
Verse four says, he was living in a town called lo debar.
That means nothing to us.
'cause that's actually Hebrew word,
but it literally means place of nothing.
He's living in the middle of nowhere.
You might say place of nothing. He's socially isolated.
Plus he's relationally estranged. He's the grandson.
Think about the grandson of the previous king
who tried to kill the new king.
So he's socially, relationally, materially impoverished.
He can't work for himself.
He needs care and provision from other people.
He's really down on top of all that.
He's emotionally damaged.
Verse eight, what does he call himself in front of David?
I'm a dead dog. Like the lowest of the low.
The dogs were cast off. They were untouchable.
They were worthless. And he's a dead one of those.
He's as low. His view of himself is as low as he could go.
Yet what did David do? Just imagine Mephibosheth.
He hears these, these rattlings of the doorframe,
and he hears these, these representatives
of the king coming into his room.
What's he thinking? He's thinking they're coming to get me.
My time is finally up
and he's walking into the throne room in front of David.
What does he expect? He expects judgment.
And David turns around and gives him assurance.
Verse seven, do not fear. That's his first words, right?
Do not fear. I'm not gonna hurt you. He gives him assurance.
He also gives him restoration.
He says, Hey, you know what all that Saul had,
I'm gonna give that all to you more than Mephibosheth had
ever had all these servants.
Now he's got those in his family. He got restoration.
He also got adoption.
David said, you're gonna eat at my table.
That's a place for family. He says, come on into my family.
I'm going to adopt you. And he got provision.
All of these Zeba
and all his family, all his servants, they have
to farm the land so that Mephibosheth has enough
and his household has enough.
Look at what David did.
I mean David couldn't heal this man,
but he brought him in, sat him at the table to
where his disability was hidden.
If everybody looks at that table, what do they see?
That's one of his sons.
God's kindness to Mephibosheth through David is stunning.
It's Hesed covenant faithfulness
to his son.
And just think about what that teaches us about God.
God seeks out the broken and the forgotten.
It is abundantly clear right here.
God's heart is to seek out the broken and the forgotten.
This man 3000 years ago deserving
judgment worth nothing in his own eyes.
It's abundantly clear that God was seeking out Mephibosheth.
But listen, that's why this is one of my favorites.
Is this not true for us too?
Is this not what God does for us
today through his grace?
Do you see the parallels here?
Let Ephesians two does a great job of explaining this.
Listen to what Ephesians two does
to describe your condition, my condition, all
of humanity's condition.
Listen to Ephesians two, one through three.
You were dead in the trespasses
and sins in which you once walked following the course
of this world, following the prince of the power of the air,
the spirits now at work in the sons of disobedience,
among whom we all once lived in the passions of our flesh,
carrying out the desires of the body, the mind.
We were by nature, children of wrath
like the rest of mankind.
So what are we spiritually broken?
Cast off living in the wasteland of sin.
We're enemies of God, we're feeling untouchable.
We feel worthless. We're actually dead in our sins.
Do you see the parallel? That's where Mephibosheth was.
That's where you and I are spiritually.
But God, Ephesians two, four says this,
but God being rich in mercy
because of the great love with which he loved us,
even when we were dead in our trespasses,
made us alive together with Christ by grace.
You've been saved and raised us up with him
and seeded us with him in the heavenly
places in Christ Jesus.
So that in the coming ages he might show the immeasurable
riches of his grace in kindness toward us in Christ Jesus.
Is that not stunningly glorious?
We deserve nothing but judgment.
We walk in that throne room, we're face down.
No, we should get judgment. What do we get? Instead?
He gives us assurance. By grace, you've been saved.
It's not your effort or your performance.
By grace, the foundation is solid by grace,
you're assured He gives us restoration.
We have far more than we ever could have imagined in him.
He gives us adoption.
We're now in Christ sons and daughters of the King.
He gives us provision that we have this immeasurable riches
with him in the heavenly places.
That's what he gives us. Instead, he doesn't wait for us
to clean ourselves up, crawl our way to the palace.
Somehow he pursues us in our brokenness.
And then he sends his son to carry us to the palace.
This is the gospel in two Samuel nine.
So here's the question. Do you see
yourself as Mephibosheth?
Like do you see yourself as desperate, as needy?
Because the reality is you will not be redeemed
until you acknowledge your need.
Because you could sit there
and think, no, I got it all together.
I'm okay. I don't need anything. I'm good with God.
I can make my way. You won't make it in
until you acknowledge your need and you're desperate
before him and say, God, I have nothing.
I'm lost. I'm desperate. I need you.
That's the first piece here.
But then if you remember what we talked about last week,
this has said kindness of God.
When We receive that, it should amaze us, yes,
stunning, and then lead us to action.
It should amaze us and lead us to action.
And so just think about this in light of two Samuel nine,
who in your life needs to hear that God chases
after the forgotten and the broken?
Like who's a mephibosheth in your life? It's you.
But then also you can be David God showing his kindness
to someone else through you.
Who is it that needs to hear that God
seeks out the broken and the forgotten?
Maybe it's the the person that's overlooked at school
or even here at church.
Maybe it's that family member who feels like a failure.
Maybe it's that neighbor going through the divorce
and he feels really lonely right now.
Maybe it's that person who just feels disqualified
because of what they've done in their past.
God showed his kindness to Mephibosheth through David.
God could have done it on his own,
but he used David through David.
We can be that vessel of kindness to others
as God has shown it to us.
First.
There's a warning here, though.
I'm not gonna read all of chapter 10 in second Samuel,
but this chapter Reveals
that our efforts to show this has said kindness of God
can at times be tragically misunderstood.
Chapter 10 10 shows us that that effort to show kindness
to others can actually be misunderstood.
Just look at verse two of chapter 10.
I'll read verse one as well.
After this, the king of the Ammonites died.
Ammonites were an enemy of God's people nearby.
After this, the king of the mites died
and hanno, his son reigned in his place
and David said, I will deal loyally.
By the way, that word loyally is the same word as kindness
in chapter nine that has said, David said,
I wanna show has said kindness.
I will deal loyally with Hanon.
The son of Nahash, as his father dealt loyally with me.
So what's David doing here? It's the same way.
He showed kindness to Mephibosheth.
He's saying, I am going to do the same thing for this Hanon,
the king of the Ammonites.
Why? Because Han nun's father had showed kindness to David.
David's like, I wanna pay him back.
I wanna return the favor. He was kind to me.
I wanna be kind to him. And so David sent representatives
to Hanno who showed up
and they were treated with skepticism and contempt.
They were thinking David was trying to spy on the Ammonites.
And they ended up humiliating David's men.
They even began to hire other nations around them
to help them fight against Israel.
And it ended up tragic.
They brought destruction upon themselves.
They in the Amite worldview, they had no category
for genuine kindness.
Like they just assumed ulterior motives
and they ended up paying the ultimate price for it.
But let's just think about that for a second.
Is that not the way the world often responds
to Christian Love today?
Is it not similar? Like somehow in our sinful
human nature, we find it easier
to believe in manipulation rather than genuine kindness.
When somebody does something kind
like, what's your angle, man?
Like what? What are you trying to get from me?
Now, some of that is because we
as Christians have not helped that process.
We do love with strings attached
sometimes, and that's a problem.
We shouldn't do that. We should love just radically.
But as we go about this pursuit of showing kindness,
will some people assume
that we have hidden agendas?
Yes. Love them anyway.
Will some people misinterpret our kindness as manipulation?
Yes. Show kindness anyway.
Will people reward our, he said with hostility,
possibly show it anyway.
Serve them anyway? You know why?
Because that's what God does for us.
Romans eight, Romans five, eight.
God shows his love for us in
that while we were still sinners, Christ died for us.
So think about that.
God sought you out when you were unable to come
to him when you were his enemy.
You were living in the wasteland of sin
and he came after you.
And so when someone misunderstands you, when someone comes
to you and rejects you because of the kind, that's okay.
You can still love him. You can still go after that.
You can still care for them. Love their heart.
Love them as a person. You can do what you can
to show the kindness of God to them that you have received.
Listen, that's one main way that the world will see
and know that our God is truly scandalously
and persistently kind.
It's because we do it for them,
because he did it for us.
There's a scene in Luke 19.
Jesus was passing through a town called Jericho,
and he met a rich tax collector named Zacchaeus.
Zacchaeus was very intrigued with this man, Jesus.
So he was interested. Now,
the way the Bible describes him was
that he was a wee little man.
This means he was short.
And so he climbed up in a sycamore tree for the Lord.
He wanted to see what's interesting here is that
as the Savior passed that way, he looked up in that tree
and he set, well, I'm gonna stop right there.
Okay, we go too far.
If you were a kid, you're singing that song right now.
But he looked up in the tree
and he, he named
this outcast, broken man.
We don't know. We assume Jesus had never met him.
Jesus is God,
but he looks up at this man who everyone else
said is worthless.
And he said, Zacchaeus.
And then he not only said his
name, he said, we're going to your house.
Let's go hang out. Now, here again, I said it a little bit,
but the religious folks were grumbling.
You know who that guy is? Jesus.
Why are you wasting your time with this guy?
And Yet, Jesus showed kindness.
Anyway,
this forgotten, broken man looked down upon
by society, looked down upon by everyone else.
Jesus came after him. And you know why?
Jesus gave us the reason?
Luke 1910, Jesus said, for the son of man came to seek
and to save the lost notice, not just came
to save, the lost came to seek and to save the lost.
That's a pursuit. That's an effort to save.
I'm coming after those who are forgotten.
I'm going after those who are broken.
I'm going after those who know they need a savior.
That's who I'm coming for.
This is what grace actually means.
It's the love that seeks out the forgotten
that makes room at the table for those who have nothing
but empty hands and a broken past.
This is the said of God that he would do that for us.
May that be our heartbeat today.
I invite you to bow your heads and pray towards that.
End with me now. And here's how I want us
to respond.
I I, I don't claim to speak for God,
but I believe by his word, he's led us
to a couple things to reflect on.
Maybe today you're sitting there
and you don't know that love of God
and you know you're forgotten.
You know you're broken. You know you're outcast
and you live in that wasteland of sin and you have no hope
and you're trying to be good enough and you're exhausted.
Listen, today, today,
hear me, hear Jesus.
He came to seek and to save the loss. That's you.
And you're like, how could somebody be so kind?
Yeah, he's the good God of the universe who loves you.
You've never seen it here on this earth,
but he proved it when he went to that cross for you.
And so if that's you
and you're like, I don't know that kind of love
he's offering, receive it.
Receive the covenant kindness of God for you,
that he would live, die,
and resurrect in your place
so that you could be with him forever.
Let's Just rest in that. Receive that today.
And if you already know that love
and you've experienced the love of of God in his kindness
for you, let today be an a refresher
reminding you where you were dead, lost, forgotten,
outcast, and he brought you in not
because you cleaned yourself up first.
He cleaned you up when he brought you in so
that you can live a new life now and be with him forever.
May that be what causes joy, that it's all his
unshakeable foundation,
abundant grace, kindness, and mercy.
Thank you God for your grace, that we don't deserve this.
It's a gift. That's grace. What we deserve is judgment.
And you don't give that to us. That's mercy. See, thank you.
God
lead us in the way of everlasting as a result of that,
lead us to worship you with all that we are as a result of
that, lead us to speak boldly, to love radically.
As a result of that.
We don't do all of this.
We don't sing and, and live and give and serve.
We don't do all of that because we need you to love us.
We do all of that because you already love us
And we're free to do it now.
Thank you, God. What a gift.